ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata dal momento che non
abbiamo ancora cucina perfetta non ho
deciso che fino a che non la otterremo
utilizzeremo questo stile un pochino più
rustico smetteremo di cercare di essere
figli perché tanto siamo all'interno
della cucina che grande così quindi come
attualmente in un bar di farlo perché
anche grande così
oggi però ho un assistente che è stata
molto apprezzata in passato può venire
commenti erika non è bello come figlio
damian green che cosa bella a tutti un
altra cosa quello che faremo oggi come
prima cittadina le break ma che volete
hanno scoperto che cosa fa rivolge
quindi stanno correndo per oggi faremo
un hamburger gigante mai perché riesco a
fare una cosa del tipo di dovessero sì
ma riesce
[Risate]
ecco i ragazzi mi spieghi perché sto per
aprire una cosa assurda non posso farla
vedere ma non c'e niente con la cucina
burro che non lo vuoi per vedere non lo
so come addio o con lusco est la realtà
virtuale non usciva più di casa e anzi
subito sotto nei commenti se volete
vedere guglielmo stremare con loculo
ma è questa recapito fanno scegliere
alle persone no arancione grazie a
regime ravenna portato a casa le
barriere che le versioni risponderebbero
segni di colpi di mazza siamo addentrati
in botto dico ai ragazzi se volete
preparare un hamburger gigante la cucina
con burger
invece di usare questo aggeggio sì
andiamo parte dal presupposto che per
fare un hamburger gigante avevano
bisogno di un panino gigante non ho
trovato adesso una parte un paio gigante
quindi l'unica opzione l'unica chance
che ho è quella di crearne uno io quello
che ho fatto quindi è stato iniziare già
da ieri sera a lavorare alla pasta del
pane è per fare un panino al latte
ammesso 280 grammi di latte intero 40
grammi di zucchero una bustina di
lievito che ho sciolto mescolando un
pochino all'interno di un pentolino ho
aggiunto 300 g di farina 00 200 g di
farina manitoba olio extravergine 20
grammi e 10 grammi di sale o trasferito
nel pasto in una ciotola che o coperto
con della pellicola trasparente e le ho
lasciate lievitare all'interno del mio
forno fino a che non è raddoppiato di
volume a quel punto ho preso una placca
da forno che os progettato con della
roba per renderla antiaderente e ho
trascritto un impasto all'interno di
quel contenitore che ho sempre messo in
un luogo asciutto e riparo da correnti
d'aria a lievitare anche nel mercato
non compro questo è il risultato di
quello che ho fatto ieri ora il problema
è che l'ho fatto levitare tutta la sera
quindi del ris gonfiarsi prima era tutto
tondo è capito sentendo bello altro
invece è stato fatto piatto ma che ci
possiamo fare niente
ok grazie al 38 ho visto la ricotta e
l'uno e dicono susan possa davvero
sì sì allora come faccio adesso è
prendere un tuorlo dichiarava interno
che mi chiede se usando per favore e
versarci del latte dentro la signora
stai facendo la cosa più terribile di
questa ricetta stai per cuocere l'uomo
no come c'è un uomo serio
vabbè ora mi schierai quello devo
riprendere da questa cosa segue possiamo
anche fare immaginare a tutte quante le
persone come stiamo facendo
a questo punto prendiamo un pennello e
cosa serve questo lo vedrai quanti
dovremmo ammettere il sesamo si
incollerà al panino e farà quell'effetto
mcdonald senza motivo si può avere ma
apriti sesamo c'è inquadrano con 12 st
che era bello sentire in colpa che possa
aggirarsi di 180 gradi per fare cosa
solamente anche di naviganti di tre
questo lo conserviamo nel fratello che
io vedo cocaina
ma non sto spiegato a te lo stratega da
che ci può cioè preso il punto di vista
di chi ti guarda giusto lì abbiamo
capito
l'abbiamo capito che l'ultimo giro per
abbiamo capito lo abbiamo capito
l'abbiamo capito lo abbiamo capito che
stai frustrando l'abbiamo capito che non
mangi ora ho capito che non mangi con la
mangi perchè disgustoso perché perché
faremo a questo punto anche un enorme un
uovo all'occhio di bue che è troppo alto
per john mark 15 continua dire ma non
mettiamo lo mettiamo non mettiamola ma
il fatto è che va messo perché così la
ricetta è ancora più particolare
ochestra un uovo gigante l'abbiamo
capita un'altra mangi non ci fermerà i
ok
vorrei far vedere il macinato l'ho preso
io poi aveva preso il macinato errato di
suino tale e quale a guglielmo allora
quello che stava per fare adesso è
creare un enorme sottiletta al césar vi
mostro subito come fare avuto
[Musica]
va beh meglio così no no sì anche perché
non abbiamo niente di meglio da offrire
prendiamo una pellicola trasparente
l'attrice mettendo a posto
il pensionato 9 con questo no perché ora
dovrà estendere v ma non vogliamo dare
un centro più formaggio zoe e allora fai
un doppio strato per tutte emma non ce
n'è abbastanza nel suo letto un'altra
quando dai ok grazie ma non dopo aver
pulito sempre tutte quante quanto lo
sono state le luride dovremmo infonderà
occhio se io sto sui 180 gradi non
un'idea già fatto con queste sottilette
una forza il tetto neruda infastidire ce
l'aveva costretta quindi a questo passo
il commento non ci vede sfidare nella
cucina di casa tua ti scoccio scanu
della cantina maga gaga fermo guarda la
plastica
secondo titolo sta buttando io da gag
schifo facciamo che tutti gli scarti
degli mercato le cam nou si vede proprio
che voi ci avete la gente che velava le
cose a casa e le bambine che stanno lì
ma che stai a di
non a questo punto nessun altro foglio
di pellicola sopra si è in con un
mattarello stand in aspetti non lo
chiamerei mattarella e per cosa lo
scovolino del cesso di agorà il tuo
spazzolino da denti c'è basta in frigo
riportiamo celani che prendiamo un chilo
di carne a verissimo in sette sas
fondammo tutta la cucina è tua
intrattieni pubblico susan no non mi
sono appena scalco lato ma scusami e
posso posso dire
posso alla mamma ammazza però ragazzi
innovazione gen
bravo basta basta che però provo a tre
girato quando vi serve a richiamare è
mark è talmente alto che fare che cela
la camera della telesorveglianza davis
tani squat metti a fare delle riprese un
po più action marta popper di napoli
ed eccoci venuti alla portata così
hamburger grazie che apre l una cosa
gabriele a destri vincere il bando
sembra guglielma natale sempre aspettato
usate che cosa prevede la ricetta la
ricetta prevede pane ecc ap nuovo
hamburger formaggio insalata pomodori
cipolla cruda maionese altro amburgo e
nulla rossa non barbecue non si fa di
più la salsa ketchup rovina tutto
cipolla rossa di cannara cosa cipolla
rossa di cannara preparando una carriera
da fare ma sta in ciò che beccando tutte
le persone come per un panino rapido 180
gradi
guardami avrà cipolla rossa di cannara
largamente no bianca a croccante si
cruda e come fa un po forse no ma non
sarebbe una buona idea cara bellarla
passo no questo chiudo un po di sale
grosso
no dobby l'elfo domestico come vice era
quella bambina non girarla come le
frittate ma prima aspetto essere freddi
ma proviamo a fare altro scommetto
adesso metto quei soldi cup e non lo
farò mai
aspetta scommetto che gianluigi ti fa
fare il salto sono io a poter un esperto
per il salto no ragazza come no
[Applauso]
ma quella che si no
mi dovete togliere al capo nord dice no
è no non ci pensare chiediamo una bella
cotta e poi dopo la risoluzione non le
ha mozzato non ci no fuori dal campo ho
detto quello che stai facendo un casino
ricompattiamo compattamento fatto il
tutto è ricompattato no perché quando lo
vai a muoversi di spalla come il
compianto le armi persano chi vota per
il nuovo salma questa tecnica mi trovo
però abbiamo delle crete nelle
infrastrutture di chiamerei dei
restauratori registro perché ho detto no
non c'è da incollante la cucina no però
ciò dicono la porta di casa che può
spettare a fare satira va bene ma se non
ti viene bollito fare la capretta sennò
prutsch i tubi facendo guglielmo guida è
possibile che si innervosisca ragazzi
sto facendo un vizio ma voi siete minuti
a rovinare il mio canale
va beh scusate vigilare ci pensano i
nostri faceva impazzire il salto tutti
immaginano le persone a casa in provaci
tu sei ripreso group si formalizza
voleva il salto per aggiungere come ma
questo non è il salto per bordo
rimettiamo dice un'idea fidati velo non
ti faccio falli questa volta gira
categoria c volo a saltare le ho mai
girato male crociani dal bravo molto
bravo grazie ai verso solofra g non
saper più a cucina mancata non si butta
niente facciamo vedere come viene
mangiato ma ligue 1 ma che servono da
vicino fosso tagliate evidente era il
momento di fare l'uomo a questo punto
per farlo è molto semplice le uova
ragazzo forte ti prego fidati ti prego
ti prego
guardami apre con una nuova con una mano
del giro io via limiti cosa domani possa
farti vedere solamente un bicchierino se
tuorli alcuni no aspetta scusami tuorli
qui alcune quindi tu le aprì qua far
scendere la segmenti di eps il tuorlo lo
sai che c'è la tecnica segreta quella
della bottiglia innanzitutto all'igiene
importantissimo che se perderà fenomeno
come trilla quest'estate mani una
sciacquata importante le mani fai uno
scherzo stupido
guardate tutti anche voi la casa era
così imparate bene come si fa fattura
voglio sembrare
track ok sì sì è vero guardate non resta
niente vero guardate che bravo bravo
bravo bravo
adesso bravo è che posso dire io in mano
vedi questa quella no veloce veloce non
ce n'è un'altra ragazza mia bacharach
ma in persona subito stagionale
conosciuto no però nel senso ha imparato
da lui
ora c'è ora non c'è ora c'è ora non c'è
ora c'è la piacevole vedere questo
esercizio skin e non vorrei sentire una
parola prego prego
grazie a una buona tecnica poi potrei
farlo da casa grazie ad un consiglio
vero su questo cancelli qualcosa verso i
tetti e salate faceva sempre nomina
fastidiosissimo ok grazie grazie che
abbado di l'acqua non ci dimenticheremo
grazie o imburrato la teglia e mettono
il coppapasta dentro staccate a spruzzo
fondamentale per queste preparazioni in
modo che non sant'angelo ricordo per
cosa ne usato lo stack antenne raduno
durante si no lo steccato dall'altra
parte qualche birra la lei perché è
stato un uomo citiamo quello ma guarda
che palla devastò mamma mia enorme ma è
più pratico l'album è vero bojan e la il
tuorlo che c'ha di valori in connessione
inglese
[Musica]
la nostra hamburger che insomma non è
una bellissima c'era ma poteva andare
peggio
come potete andare molto meglio non se
avessimo fatto quello che stavo dicendo
io ai falli che è praticamente pronto
fermi di ricami sesto carbonizzando
carbonizzato no ma ho sentito cemento
sulle lane e qualche complotto però non
ti quadro la sigla a tema alla mamma mia
ragazzi andiamo avanti ragazzi a testa
alta ma è un veloce cosa gli sta
trasmettendo in alta grande morbidezza
giunta glielo devi fare quel bordino dà
fastidio è vero ma mai fastidio quanto
me li dai tu non pensavo che questa
ricetta potesse diventare un condimento
fiorano ha detto all'inizio un panino o
un bel ciambellone l'uomo non sapendo
simpatici udine il travaglio del
pomodoro ii s
apriamo a questo punto la sottile tona
eccomi ti serve grazie
dobbiamo mettere sopra il panino né
bella grossa bella ciotta tentativo e
poi c'è il colombo crede e 1
[Musica]
schifo chiudiamo col tappo vedete è la
sottiletta incominciare a campione ad
appassire che a squagliarsi ricordiamoci
sistema presento una ricetta che hanno
tagliato i pomodori luogo estra pronto
il pane è quello mi manca solo la
cipolla e siamo a posto taglio della
cipolla di s guardate qua sì esatto
guglielmo questo è bello vedere pronti a
comporre i dieci come tiri fuori quel
coso dalla padella arriviamo perché apre
sembra fare un salto non esagerare per
favore anzi diciamo di più
sì sembra di una scena dei cost e low
tutta la testa barbecue ma in grande
quanto un piatto st hamburger ma lo vedi
che cosa ci va solo la ne ha bisogno di
molte stanze per montaggio stampa io
metterei anche dell'olio d'oliva
extravergine dato nel bicchiere accanto
alla fine stacca quella valletta già una
persona 20 dopo è perfetto sopra però i
soliti consigli è bravo già arrivato il
momento di mettere la mia persona questo
è un momento delicatissimo se fallisci
qua perdiamo o mio dio
bravissimo insalata pomodori e poi la
cipolla anelli di cipolla cruda ma è sì
ci sta e del polso per vediamo se ti
entra il braccialetto di cipulli e
secondo me l'entrata bene ma lascia
stare un attimo allunga la mano questo
quest'anno trovato ti viene da piangere
si è emozionata vederlo
è infine ma io decisione ma è vanessa
team e con la maionese poi abbonda un po
di più cosa si è fatto praticamente di
20 centimetri enorme ragazzi dunque
morbido sapete pure cosa si dovrebbe
fare con questi anni la torta di
compleanno stata sì io te lo faccio per
il tuo compleanno con quelli sono tre
big mac
quando arriva l'hamburger gigante inizia
il mio parlare e inizia al mio zittire
le voglio qui c'è il forno da qualche
palla e porlo gianni un solo libero se
libero le cappe se ho una mia questo che
un po r co food porca come molto
difficile da e tale sicuramente molto
efficiente genere ma vogliamo provare
mai un momento un momento no allora ma
se il pdl sarà pericoli all ero l'uomo
aspetta che armi è buono il pane non mi
convince affatto comparto di questo non
c'è la città a mangiarlo tutto è poi a
meno che non hai una boccata da squadra
non riprovarci girarlo bocca da fuoco
no non lo dice ma boricchi ma
qualcos'altro dire avuto l'ok a
rimettersi in forma comunque ragazzina e
mamma mi faccio schifo comunque detto
ciò la notte due tra nino del feto
career high
vabbè tutti apprezzato e ci starà gatti
il salto cioè mi è piaciuta questa
ricetta iscrivetevi a questo canale
mettete un po di gente in su per i
nostri perché ne avremo bisogno dopo
questo è come sempre ci vediamo hanno
come sempre
questa volta però se settimana ci
vediamo nel cuore prima martedì con il
primo blog settimana di questo canale
ciao ciao ciao
adesso tutto come fare